régis le sommier grand reporter rt
france bonsoir régis alors hier le
bonheur et la réconciliation avait l'air
simple comme un coup de fil mais
aujourd'hui quand même jean yves le
drian précise qu'il faudrait quand même
montré des preuves d'amour à des actes
pour sortir de cette crise déjà à quel
acte concret on pourrait penser et
peut-on s'attendre de washington
écoutez le problème c'est tout le
problème est là aujourd'hui il ya eu un
affront il ya un contrat de 50 milliards
de dollars qui a échappé à la france
alors il y aura évidemment des
compensations financières parce que on
engage pas c'est ce contrat d'ailleurs a
été signée il ya plusieurs années il
engagé un certain nombre d'ouvriers je
pense en particulier à ceux de la région
de cherbourg moi j'en connais
personnellement qui travaille pour laval
navale groupe et qui aujourd'hui
s'interrogent sur l'avenir de leur
emploi également en australie parce que
ça ce contrat comment ne recoupent et
quelques quarante mille personnes en
australie et 60% des sous marins étaient
prévus les peut-être construit sur le
continent australien donc c'est beaucoup
on était allé très loin on avait engagé
beaucoup de choses je rappelle qu'au
moment où toni morrison le premier
ministre australien décide de annonce la
rupture de ce contrat est bien les
australiens avaient envoyé un courrier à
la france sera expliquant toute leur
satisfaction sur l'avancée du projet des
sous-marins français donc contradiction
totale et là puisque ce sont les
américains qui ont décidé et on comprend
très bien on le voit très bien que c'est
une décision stratégique des américains
de reprendre la main dans cette zone
pour faire face à la chine en imposant
leur technologie une technologie
d'ailleurs qui on le rappelle n'arrivera
pas avant 2040 alors que celle de la
france était prévu pour 2030 donc quand
on connaît l'état d'avancer l'âge de la
flotte chinoise et l'évolution rapide de
l'armement chez les chinois qu'on est
sensé contrecarrer dans cette zone ça
fait que très tard donc il y à une
interrogation qui demeure c'est pourquoi
tout ça s'est arrêté pourquoi les
américains et pourquoi les australiens
ont décidé jeu mon de faire bande à part
et de d'humilier les français et la
question aujourd'hui deux de renvoyer de
rappeler les ambassadeurs de les
renvoyer de faire des coups de fil de de
faire des entretiens bilatéraux comme il
ya eu aujourd'hui entre le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken et le
ministre des affaires étrangères jean
yves le drian tout ça c'est de la
diplomatie je dirais que c'est une une
façade c'est pour montrer qu'on ne perd
pas la face maintenant la question de la
nature des actes qui pourraient
compenser cette perte de contrats et
bien elle reste inconnue on ne sait pas
si les américains autoriseront les
français puisque la question et tout est
là aussi puisque on est on est dans
cette alliance la france réparti de
l'otan la france est liée aux etats-unis
elle a décidé de lier sa diplomatie osez
à celle des états unis en réintégrant
sous nicolas sarkozy le commandement
intégré de l'otan eh bien ça nous bloque
certaines façons et comme je les ai déjà
dit sur cette antenne le problème de la
france c'est qu'elle devrait aujourd hui
au nom c'est à regarder à nous et outre
alliance il y à des acteurs dans la
région il ya des acteurs dans le monde
je parle je pense en particulier aux
turcs aux iraniens et même aux russes
puisque c'était une des intentions
premières d'emmanuel macron de deux
façons finalement à ne pas être à la
remorque des états unis puisque on se
rend compte que en dépit de cette crise
et puis des commandes et des salamalecs
parce que c'est de ça qu'il faut parler
concret auquel on a assisté ces jours
derniers eh bien la france est considéré
comme un partenaire secondaire un
partenaire sur lesquels on peut
s'essuyer les pieds véritablement je
pense que ça a provoqué la colère des
manuels maquereau en colère vraiment
profonde maintenant quelle va être la
réponse stratégique de la france les
états unis ont décidé de montrer qu'ils
avaient une stratégie différente dans
cette zone en australie et en inde et
nous quelle va être la nôtre pour les
années à venir je pense qu'on est
actuellement un moment pivot sur la
commande le la politique étrangère de la
france en général je justement vous
l'avez évoqué vous avez déjà enquêté sur
ma deuxième question effectivement
l'opposition français s'agace de
jean-luc mélenchon à marine le pen de 7
entre guillemets molette française pour
pour résumer un petit peu tous les
tweets et aimer les maires macro aurait
dû être inspiré d'être un peu plus ferme
justement parce que c'est sûr que ces
rappels d'ambassadeur les retrouvailles
fin octobre ça fait pas forcément bonne
impression à tout le monde en france
bah écoutez ça c'est un cetain le
minimum que mc emmanuel macron pouvait
faire il ya à chaque fois qu'on rappelle
son ambassadeur ça veut dire qu'il ya
crise les propos de jean yves le drian
aussi ne cachait pas justement le fait
qu'il y avait une rupture de quelque
chose maintenant une semaine plus tard
on se rend compte que un coup de fil
suffit à commander un petit peu à calmer
les esprits que on
dialogue mais que dans les fêtes de la
part de la france aucune mesure décisive
non n a été prise alors la question
aussi c'est la pl peut-être la place de
la france dans l'otan un souvenons nous
des années de la fin des années 70 le
général de gaulle a décidé
unilatéralement de retirer la france du
commandement intégré de l'otan à
l'époque ça avait provoqué effectivement
à taulé le général de gaulle avait
d'ailleurs une politique qui était bien
plus comme en politique que de se
plaçant entre la russie et les etats
unis à l'époque on était en pleine
guerre froide et ils avaient eu ce
courage de retirer la france de cette
alliance qui semblait ne pas convenir à
cette position à la position stratégique
qui a la politique étrangère de la
france aujourd'hui le problème c'est ce
suivisme dont on a fait preuve depuis je
rappelle encore davantage depuis le
retour de la france dans le commandement
intégré sous nicolas sarkozy
on a été suiviste des états unis et on a
ça nous a peut-être empêché d'avoir une
vision stratégique une vision mondiale
propre même si elle doit s'inscrire dans
un jeu d'alliances et qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de rompre avec nos alliés
traditionnels mais il y a il faut faire
entendre notre voix et notre voix ne se
fait pas assez entendre sur beaucoup de
conflits on a été absents sur beaucoup
de deux zones le monde est en train de
changer on le voit le retrait des
américains d'afghanistan
le ver cela donne cette ce retour des
américains dans la zone australienne
face à la chine bouleverse la donne et
il est important que la france se
repositionne jeu plage irait aussi
peut-être et rapidement s'il vous plaît
parce qu'on arrive au bout est ce
qu'elle en a les moyens la france 2 de
se repositionner de et de poser et de
compter écoutez depuis que la france est
présente en afrique avec l'opération
comment d'abord serval puis barkan la
france a montré qu'elle était capable de
se projeter en opérationnel à l'étranger
qu'elle est capable de 2 comment de tuer
un des leader djihadiste l'a fait encore
la semaine dernière avec abou walid al
sahraouis qui était le patron de
l'olivier est de l'état islamique dans
le grand sahara elle a cette capacité de
projection également souvenez vous de
l'opération hamilton sur la syrie où la
france a mené seule cette opération
depuis ses bases aériennes françaises
jusqu'à la syrie donc quand elle veut se
déployer la france est capable de le
faire elle a une flotte sous-marine
conséquente c'est une puissance
considérable ils font qu'elle fasse
notre de cette puissance et il faut
aussi qu'elle regarde dans les zones
dans lesquelles elle opère peut-être moi
je pense particulièrement à la turquie
il y a eu un presque un affrontement
entre la france et la turquie autour
autour de la grèce et au tour justement
des gisements d'hydrocarbures qui sont
larges de cette zone que la cube qui
convoite la france ça s'est porté au
secours de la grèce là d'une certaine
façon jouer le rôle que l'europe ne joue
pas et mais il est important peut-être
aussi pour la france d'entamer un
dialogue et d'essayer de voir des
alliances stratégiques justement avec un
certain nombre de pays et on n'est pas
obligés d'en référer constamment aux
états unis parce qu'on voit que eux
quand ils font leur accord quand ils
vont voir les australiens quand ils vont
voir les anglais et bien nous en parle
pas et à la fin ça nous coûte 50
milliards de dollars ça fait cher
effectivement l'addition merci avoue
régis le sommier d'avoir été avec nous
de nous avoir apporté votre analyse